soixante solution face au changement
climatique une exposition qui fait le
tour du monde
c'est à la bibliothèque départementale
de la réunion que les photographies de
yann arthus-bertrand continuent leur
tournée à travers 21 une photo l' agence
française de développement et la
fondation goodplanet met en lumière des
solutions concrètes dans la lutte contre
le changement climatique
la bibliothèque départementale et la
direction de l'environnement ont mis en
place des ateliers pour les scolaires
pendant une semaine les jeunes ont été
sensibilisés au thème du changement
climatique
à
à l'occasion de la 11e édition des
week-ends nature une conférence de
presse a lieu à l'espace réglée du bas
de la rivière du 10 au 31 octobre 2015
le département de la réunion propose de
vivre une expérience de découverte ou de
redécouverte des espaces naturels
sensibles répartis sur toute l'île ces
sites abritent un patrimoine naturel
unique aux paysages somptueux et à la
biodiversité exceptionnelle sujet au
coeur de l'actualité internationale le
conseil départemental a décidé pour
cette édition 2015 de sensibiliser le
public sur le changement climatique
comme chaque année la collectivité offre
une véritable invitation au voyage au
travers de plus de 180 visite guidée
gratuite